[Music]
so we're looking through the pain yeah
remember that uh remember that like
about about a couple months ago we we
talked about uh people accusing brendan
schaub of potentially seeing a nick
schwartzen joke we played the clips back
to back
uh well they finally addressed it being
a cuck because i was turned into one yes
well that's a great way to start a clip
let me go ahead and start that again
that's a weird i don't know why
being a cuck because i was turned into
one yes i don't know if you watched nick
schwartzen on
theo vaughn i don't watch anybody else's
play nick
what a weird thing to say
okay defensive
i don't watch anybody else's podcast is
a lie
we've heard him tell other fighters to
their face that he watches their podcast
well he's probably lying then okay
was and why is that
sitting like he's about to get a laptop
this is how i sit sometimes
you don't sit like that sometimes
he's [ __ ] jiminy glick over here
[ __ ] sit still bro it's like i'm
brian callum i'm going to beat him up
when i see him
i'm going to beat nick up we're going to
get him on the podcast
and he's going i'm bryan count nick
schwartz and one of my favorite people
he's the best i love him
and then he's called you fifa i think i
found out why chicago has an adderall
shortage hey check out brian callan's
past tour dates
was he in chicago and also check early
life just to be safe southerland which
is hilarious he remember when he came
when he was on the final kid back at the
old studio yeah and he roasted us he
said i look like an italian lego
it's pretty funny actually okay hold on
that's actually pretty funny
nick is the guy i just talked the
funniest guy i just talked to him
well let's calm down he was he's doing
some moving but uh he's doing some coke
allegedly yeah i love him and he is
usually one of the funniest people on
the planet well i have the clip here so
let's set it up with the clip especially
for the people listening so it's a clip
of nick schwartzen and theo von talking
the title says nick swartz and brennan
shaw both like fajitas yeah so
oh cause of the oh yeah this is the one
that we played we played this clip on
the show oh there's been you know
whatever bottom dwellers being like oh
jobs stole a bottom dwellers
bottom dwellers huh bottom dwellers
really
hey let's look at that algorithm and see
who who's who's whose videos pop up when
they search your fighter in the kid
huh bottom dwellers
[ __ ] the only person that's a bottom
dweller is you next to joe rogan's
[ __ ] you [ __ ] short short wear and
[ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ dude you're
embarrassing you're the only person that
could kick my ass and i wouldn't even
respect you for doing it
you're literally a parasite yeah
seriously
i'd call you a remora fish but that's
unfair to them because they keep the
shark clean
big swords in the heat
you're the opposite you [ __ ] on the
shark
before you must have done a special on i
don't know about fajitas
oh i'm sorry yes forget it yeah you did
a whole no you're the one who did a
whole special about fajitas and
schwartzen did a special and did a bit
i had a bit on fajitas i had a bit of
fajitas that i took from nick schwartzen
and anybody who criticized me in any way
is a hater and a bottom feeder and if
you don't believe me i'll have my drag
big gay lion come defend me
and boy will he defend me yeah and
remember my girl's mexican right what
first
no
i didn't know that oh so that's where
you came up with all that material from
i have a few apologies for withdrawing
from real life experiences i have some
apology emails to send merch
now i get the name of the special it
completely changes everything no wonder
he had to do five takes for 25 minutes
of material
so yeah but you wrote a lot of we're at
you you steal a lot of jokes
is he about to say you write a lot of
food jokes
which is that a compliment
mexican food
that's the whole thing
he did it he did say it please go back
please go back and play it and don't
interrupt it i have to hear that
[Music]
i saw it coming
what the [ __ ] man
that's strolling i don't know about
fajitas and i had a bit on fajitas and
remember my girls mexican right so yeah
but you wrote a lot of we had all food
mexican foods yeah a ton of them so the
food
it's true he did have a lot of mexican
food jokes
of all the [ __ ] that we've done of
brendan
this is my favorite five seconds yeah
that was awesome friend is [ __ ] on
him his own friend is saying you write a
lot of mexican food jokes so maybe it's
maybe too many
probably don't do any more are you
counting my gnome sayings you know what
i'm saying
fajitas when i'm saying how embarrassing
is like going uh bottle surface of the
club like we were fajitas like
yeah yeah we know we i've seen nick
schwartzen special
oh you're like geez like it's
embarrassing like everyone said steve
has a joke and watches you i'm sure
so
i do it's not especially anything i do
that bit at the comedy store i wrote it
i don't know right before i went on
right you wrote that
they wrote it down you wrote it that
like is written material
yeah he's got to use those crowns for
something mitzi sure is rolling in her
grave
oh my god right so i do that bit maybe
three times and then some fan was like
oh that's like nick schwartzen's bit
so he's been called out for it before to
his face
by the way this is the same guy who just
said i love nick schwartz and he's so
great at then before that saying i don't
listen to people's podcast specifically
because the swordsman was brought up and
he knew this was coming
and but then he does listen to other
people's podcasts because he talks about
it yo you don't talk about b i was like
listen to other podcasts
i know nick has a fajita but he goes
yeah and this is what people don't
realize community i'm stupid yeah i'm
dumb so please explain it to me like i'm
four my brain is broken
i put the dvd out of by nick swartz and
special in the show links in case anyone
wanted to watch it on their own you know
on their own just to make their own
comparison okay sure here it is
there it is
i remember that special it was all about
faith it was
honestly it was a master class and how
you could just take one
mundane topic and be funny for an hour
bro remember his 15-minute bell pepper
skit alone in that i remember the
reviewers were saying it was
carlon-esque i know it really was it
really was and honestly they said the
sizzle impression that he did sounded
like they were at a mexican restaurant
honestly nick schwartzen should win a
[ __ ] a daytime emmy for this
um
[Music]
i want to hear brendan explain comedy to
me and how it's
please do you sure please okay the
comedy community is pretty tight knit we
all know each other so and you all hate
each other
protect your comedian affair anyone
learn the true power all i do is nick is
a friend his text and go hey man heard
you up fajita bit i have a new bit that
i wrote about fajitas you have fajita
videos i have something like it what's
your premise i know fajitas how
embarrassingly or fajitas it's sizzling
it's like we're in bottle serves the
clebus not exactly like not exactly like
mine i can see how people see it i went
all good not gonna do it anymore
here's what happened he stole nick
schwartzen joke he got caught he knew it
was going to get back to nick schwartzen
because he's figuring it out now how
this works
so he front lashed and said hey i'm
doing this that way he could later go
like oh as soon as i find out what's him
i stopped instead of the truth of the
matter is that fajita joke wasn't even
on an x watson special it was just like
recorded
you know like when he was like doing a
set somewhere right
and he probably saw it on youtube
thought this isn't a big enough video or
a special where people are going to know
or find out and he did it
or he knew that the bit was nick's worth
since he was never going to use it on a
special but he needed filler because he
only had 25 minutes of material that
were mostly about tortillas and salsa
and he's like how can i do all that and
then not close with my fajita bit yeah
you have to close yeah
you have to close on a high note yeah
so i've done that so many times what's
that aggressively attack one of your
asian jokes
i was gonna say
unless fajita jokes are aggressively
attacking your asia your tiny asian
friend because you think that he was a
hacker that took down brendan chop's
family callum's like i've done that too
man i remember when i was at mad tv like
60 of my pitches were fajita related
humor
honestly the pool boy thing i was
supposed to be holding a plate of
fajitas the whole time they mixed it and
they just kept saying dude stop drop the
fajita thing it's nick sports it's next
towards joe since
everyone knows that nick schwartzen is
the world's premier fajita
again again they kept saying you don't
remember his special that he did nick
schwartzen fajitas
that is so [ __ ] stupid
i love the pessy
the low effort like that when he just
slaps something it's always the best
speaking of low effort i also made you
guys start the house okay uh i am
putting it in the show link
right now there you go okay this is from
this is from earlier but i just whipped
it together thank you oh
very nice
i can see it
diaz persona city
[Music]
[Laughter]
very good jonathan banks dude that was
really good
so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna get we're gonna we're gonna get to
the communists we're gonna time by the
feet
gus fring was from chile the whole
thing's coming together it is
it's coming full
circle i had a t-rex joke and there was
a guy who did a t-rex joke and i
realized i realized this joke would be
so much better if it was about pieces
and then i yeah so i had a t-rex joking
and this other guy had a t-rex joke and
i realized one day we should both be
ashamed of ourselves
and then i left my wife and kids
oh
look at at least rogue is letting him
back on the show on the dunce chair yeah
it was just his way back up he's in the
he's in that baby chair for a little
while
so it used to kill i stopped doing it
and by the way i'm never
worried about right i had
seen it i had seen it before that so
it's like justin mckinney justin
mckinney's a great comic and he had this
[ __ ] hilarious bumblebee joke
i don't want to be around anymore
can we hear it ryan can i please know
this but we want to hear the bumblebee
joke it's probably a good bumblebee joke
where he's like if you see it if you see
don't let's get into the bit the only
bumblebee joke i know is
his seinfeld playing an animated one
here we go if you see it if you see
a [ __ ] car on the highway with the
doors open
and it's empty it's because there was a
bumblebee in my car or something like
that
what
oh that was a really funny joke guys did
you miss it
no i think i pretty much got it
then why aren't you laughing because i
got it that's good that's a good joke
[Music]
yeah it's genius i had seen it's genius
it's transcendent
it's not even comedy at that point
it's definitely not it's a statement on
our culture it's about bumblebees
i really don't i wrote this four of our
zeitgeist it really does i wrote a wasp
killed it i remember it was different
enough but let me tell you speaking of
adderall look at [ __ ] brendan's hands
did was it was i influenced by justin
mckinney i don't know
yes
well thinking yeah well i don't know i
wasn't even influenced by nick swords
i've never seen i've never seen his app
bro it's so funny because there was an
entire screenplay that was word for word
like jaws
and was parallel thinking
it's just parallel thinking yeah i wrote
it in 98 so i think i'm sorry i didn't
know you i didn't know [ __ ] i didn't
know your movie studio had a monopoly on
sharks
i
i just know i i don't watch a ton of
comments guys justin mckinney's the only
one allowed to talk about bees
i guess that's just it guys
i guess everyone just pack up your bee
jokes give them to justin cause he's the
only guy allowed to talk he's the
premier b expert comedy star that's why
mr burns made him head b guy
yes
influenced by nick schwartz i've never
seen i've never seen his hour i've never
seen i just know
i i don't watch a ton of comedy i've or
do a bunch of comedy yeah really you
just have nothing to do with comedy or
understand comedy or succeed at comedy
never seen a special i've never seen
anything you don't steal you've had them
on yeah i know you don't steal jokes
because then you'd be funny
hey brendan you've been in comedy longer
than you were ever a fighter and people
still refer to you as an ex-ufc fighter
call me all anyone needs to know about
your [ __ ] career
so silly but also it's not worth talking
about because this is hella seven
minutes later harry's but i love thiefer
mcsullivan so funny and and um
uh but i remember when i watched kevin
hart i think it's called laughing at my
pain and he talks about his dad the
whole time i went i should it's super
weird that somebody that wants to get
into comedy like shaw keeps saying
things like i don't watch other comedy
right
it's like it's odd it's like
it's like that's like eventually go to
tom brady and you go hey tom you know
what do you think about the way aaron
rodgers is playing goes i don't really
watch a lot of football you know that's
a lie that's all they you know what i
mean like if you want to be good at
something
that's what you do you know i didn't
watch a lot of stand-up when i was when
i started doing stand-up that's just
because i also didn't want to like steal
people's of course
subconsciously get their [ __ ] in my head
so i just
whatever
to start writing about my dad and guess
what turns out i couldn't because it was
all redacted because my dad was in the
c.i.a so i wrote a whole i wrote an
hour-long comedy act that's fully
redacted and all the [ __ ] my entire
set list is just black bars by the way
brian callan redacted there you go pessy
good luck with that album cover
i had 50 minutes on my [ __ ] dad
usually that's how it works man yeah
sometimes like i'll see a bit like i
figured what comic's doing a bit cause i
had a bit about mexicans crossing the
border right
oh my god with the mexicans bro
and you know obsessed with them than
trump
holy [ __ ]
about my wife should be obsessed with
your your wife who's a mexican stop
asking for blow jobs in an f-150
raptor i'll put respect on your name
yeah i saw somebody do the bit and it
was so good yeah
so well
what was parallel thinking it was so
good about mexicans coming to america
by the way first off what a broad
description there's probably millions of
jokes about border jumping or mexicans
coming across there's not like one joke
specifically the nick swartz thing which
your jokes were pretty much almost beat
for beat the same joke
there's you could tell
all three of us tell a different [ __ ]
mexican border joke and it would be
completely original you know
yep
i'm not doing that better yeah sometimes
i can't compete with that i've seen
that's the best but
as far as for example what do you call
an illegal immigrant an illegal mexi in
mexico that doesn't want to work
guatemalan mexicans across the you know
this i think it's santino's bit about
morello i was going to say honduran well
that's good too actually he does the he
does the
i think all the hondurans we should send
them to memphis so they see what real
crime's like
it's interesting he does the accent and
everything i'm like hey i can't do
accents like that really because you
[ __ ] doing a great impression of a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
b there were [ __ ] specials over here
was so much smarter intelligent than my
bit i'm good previously uh and green
good peppy and yeah i literally i saw
that
factory then probably went oh i'm the
i'm not doing the i've done that and the
only common thing was about them
crossing the border and his was
so unique and such a good take i went oh
no that's so much better mine i'm out
one of the reasons i don't watch i i've
never watched a lot of comedy is because
i'm always afraid of that but you just
like
talked about all the comedy specials
you've seen and you literally watch so
much comedy you know some [ __ ] random
dudes b-bit like what are you talking
about guys just spent 10 minutes talking
to both sides of your mouth who's the
guy that we didn't know that brian kyle
got mad at that we didn't know i already
found a magical al magical remember that
these guys don't even [ __ ] know who
helped magical
[ __ ] up bro who cares about your stupid
your stupid little la comic crew
like i'm always afraid i'm gonna steal
something or i'm going to see something
you know and not steal it but just
subconsciously because you're afraid of
getting arrested [ __ ] brian that
should be your number one concern you
can see some [ __ ] and it'll get in your
head and the next thing you know two
years later you write a bit and you
think it was a right that can come from
you don't know you can't control i
haven't had that problem yeah like you
haven't either the only
parallel thing i've had is this fajita
bit but like theo said yeah i talked
theo yesterday he's like hold on you
think you are the only two comics that
worked fajitas and got embarrassed yeah
he's like dude
even before nick i heard a fajita bit
people who steal jokes get found out
yeah and that's i was gonna say
especially in today's age like back in
the day there he is it's our boy there
he is b g l b g
you know what this is like here you go
let me go back up here
maybe i'll spit something
people who steal jokes get found out
yeah and this i was gonna say especially
in today's so this is uh
this is the fighter and kid and then the
corner is what you get when you order it
from wish
yes
it's like back in the day like i'll name
i can name some comments i've stolen oh
wow they just put them in the pay no
mind list yeah they don't care more
friends bits
life catches up with them you just you
can't get away especially in today's
side with social media and podcast
there's no way to get away with it you
won't have a career you'll get found out
and as you guys are both pointing out
it's something that shut up fergie sorry
i do that out of instinct
it's on your mind whenever a producer
talks it used to be shut up frozen but i
can't help it now as the worst
accusation you could have as a stand-up
comedian that you steal other jokes the
worst first off you know where you
learned that guys
san francisco comedy college
we graduated with 3.7 gpa
challenge accepted show links all right
let's see what we have
there it is
brian callan's album about a shad
redacted
and it's all blurred out too
it all
he just can't tell any of the jokes
that one got me hell [ __ ] got me my
my favorite joke from that special was
[Laughter]